for the tenth time this winter
California has been hit with what
meteorologists call an atmospheric River
narrow bands of tropical moisture that
dump lots of rain in a short amount of
time creating a mess for residents
people who live in the town of Baja have
lost everything the levy holding back a
nearby River collapsed on Friday night
the town's mayor tweeted he has appealed
for state and federal help he said it
will take months for residents to repair
their homes
farther south in the mountains near Los
Angeles rain isn't the only threat
several meters of snow have fallen in
the area trapping residents in their
homes and creating safety hazards the
weight of the snow as it comes down and
as it starts to freeze will compress or
it'll drop on the gas meters causing
them to to back up and cause gas leaks
unless they had a couple fires in the
area due to that Laura Euler said after
two weeks of snow the last thing she
needs is rain I put tarps around my big
berm so it wouldn't flood my house
what Lori Euler and tens of thousands of
California residents would love to see
right now a break in the weather so they
can rebuild their lives Rosalind Jordan
Al Jazeera